you mentioned you've open sourced alpha
fold uh and even the data involved to me
personally also
really happy and a big thank you for
open sourcing majoko
uh the physics simulation engine that's
um that's often used for robotics
research and so on so i think that's a
pretty gangster move uh so what what's
the
what's i mean this
very few companies or people would do
that kind of thing what's the philosophy
behind that you know it's a case-by-case
basis and in both those cases we felt
that was the maximum benefit to humanity
to do that and and the scientific
community in one case the robotics
physics community with majoko so
purchased it we purchased
to obs we purchased it for the express
principle to open source it so
um so uh you know i hope people
appreciate that it's great to hear that
you do and then the second thing was and
mostly we did it because the person
building it is uh uh uh would not it was
not able to cope with supporting it
anymore because it was it got too big
for him his amazing professor uh who who
built it in the first place so we helped
him out with that and then with alpha
folds even bigger i would say and i
think in that case we decided that there
were so many downstream applications of
alpha fold um that we couldn't possibly
even imagine what they were so the best
way to accelerate uh drug discovery and
also fundamental research would be to to
um give all that data away and and and
the and the and the system itself um you
know it's been so gratifying to see what
people have done that within just one
year which is a short amount of time in
science and uh it's been used by
over 500 000 researchers have used it we
think that's almost every biologist in
the world i think there's roughly 500
000 biologists in the world professional
biologists have used it to to look at
their proteins of interest um
we've seen amazing fundamental research
done so a couple of weeks ago front
cover there was a whole special issue of
science including the front cover which
had the nuclear pore complex on it which
is one of the biggest proteins in the
body the nuclear poor complex is a
protein that governs all the nutrients
going in and out of your cell nucleus so
they're like little hot gateways that
open and close to let things go in and
out of your cell nucleus so they're
really important but they're huge
because they're massive doughnut rings
shaped things and they've been looking
to try and figure out that structure for
decades and they have lots of you know
experimental data but it's too low
resolution there's bits missing and they
were able to like a giant lego jigsaw
puzzle use alpha foal predictions plus
experimental data and combined those two
independent sources of information uh
actually four different groups around
the world were able to put it together
the sec more or less simultaneously
using alpha fault predictions so that's
been amazing to see and pretty much
every pharma company every drug company
executive i've spoken to has said that
their teams are using alpha fold to
accelerate whatever drugs uh uh they're
trying to discover so i think the
knock-on effect has been enormous in
terms of uh the impact that uh alpha
fold has made and it's probably bringing
in it's creating biologists it's
bringing more people into the field
um
both on the excitement and both on the
technical skills involved
and um
it's almost like uh a gateway drug to
biology yes it is you get more
computational people involved too
hopefully and and i think for us you
know the next stage as i said you know
in future we have to have other
considerations too we're building on top
of alpha fold and these other ideas i
discussed with you about protein protein
interactions and and genomics and other
things and not everything will be open
source some of it will will do
commercially because that will be the
best way to actually get the most
resources and impact behind it in other
ways some other projects will do
non-profit style um and also we have to
consider for future things as well
safety and ethics as well like but you
know synthetic biology there are you
know there is dual use and we have to
think about that as well with alpha fold
we you know we consulted with 30
different bioethicists and and other
people expert in this field to make sure
it was safe before um we released it so
there'll be other considerations in
future but for right now you know i
think alpha fold is a kind of a gift
from us to to to the scientific
community
you